hallo leute vor kurzem haben wir ein
video darüber gemacht wie ähnlich
deutsch und dänisch sind und unter
diesem video gab es ganz viele
kommentare die wissen wollten wie
ähnlich denn deutsch und niederländisch
sind daraufhin haben wir einen aufruf
gemacht und nina hat sich gemeldet ich
nina wo kommst du her
ich komme aus belgien und du hast schon
seit wie lange deutsch gelernt
seit ungefähr vier oder fünf jahren nina
ist jetzt 20 und hat schon sehr früh
angefangen und du sprichst wirklich fast
akzentfrei deutsch als muttersprache
deutsch ich bin echt begeistert sie
guckt schon seit vier jahren zusammen
und wir möchten euch heute zeigen wie
ähnlich oder unähnlich deutsch und
niederländisch sind dann fangen wir an
wir haben auch eine kleine liste gemacht
und daran hat unter anderem auch unsere
zuschauerinnen birte mitgearbeitet
vielen dank ich werde mal deutsch
vorlesen und nina dann das
niederländische wort welche aussprache
wisse sprechen das flämische
niederländisch oder das niederländische
niederländisch weil also die flämische
variante meine muttersprache ist werde
ich versuchen also werde ich tatsächlich
frieden sprechen aber ich werde
besonders darauf achten das ist nicht zu
dialekt wird also so schön ausgesprochen
wie man dass er so in den flämischen
nachrichten machen würde
ok fangen wir an deutsch niederländisch
jede lons tag der tag gedacht die schule
disco der zahn
frischfisch ärgerlich die bäckerei die
batterie
beschädigt bist ja nichts zum beispiel
diese slots ich glaube der ist ganz
einzigartig für das niederländisch dass
man es und dank und viele kinder haben
auch probleme damit sogar ich als ich
klein war
dann sagte ich die sagt medina cisco und
da stand ich so mit zwei anderen kindern
und wer mal gesagt aber es ist so und
dann zurück und im englischen ist es
dann viel einfacher geworden da sind es
dann nur noch school also wirklich zwei
viel deutlichere laute ja der besuch
wird besuch der mund zu mund und der
inhalt der in haut die luftdicht die
pflicht die pflicht die dauer der durch
die kunst der kunst essen beten die
erfahrung der erfahrung die frau zu frau
geduldig geduldig jemand wie man die
luftfeuchtigkeit den licht 50 hertz hat
sich ganz ähnlich an oder ja und wenn
man das jetzt noch schöner aussprechen
würde sondern hängt also das sagen die
niederländer die lange hält und auf
lebenslange hat also nichts abgeordnet
also nichts richtig heiß sodass wir man
so die minimalen unterschieden zwischen
in zwei sprachen okay lass uns das mal
ganz schnell aussprechen
die luftfeuchtigkeit luftfeuchtigkeit
total einfach rennen rennen und das ist
total nämlich total ähnlich sauer süß
teilen thelen überschätzen
uwes rathenow west shuttles ratten
das steht bei diesen was im hals
unter anderem um die andere und
zugänglich um zur ankele um touran klick
um zur ankele wetten werden und zweifeln
zu erfüllen
zwei fällen zu werfen
das waren jetzt die wörter die wir extra
ausgesucht haben weil sie sehr ähnlich
sind und jetzt wollen wir eine spontane
runde machen um einfach mal ja ich würde
sagen ich sag mal einen satz auf deutsch
und darüber setzt ihn auf niederländisch
einfach etwas was mir gerade einfällt
weil dann kriegt ihr so ein bisschen das
gespür dafür wie viele wörter ähnlich
sind ist auch die satz strukturell nicht
ich fange an mit janisch hat hunger und
kaufte sich etwas zu essen
januar zum diäten diane spielt den
ganzen tag gitarre piano spielt der
helaba kitas und jannis findest du es
ähnlich sehe nicht okay was jetzt wird
sie haben sich übermütig ja nicht
behauptet man müsste niederländisch gar
nicht lernen
aber wir haben gleich nämlich noch einen
test für janisch und dann sehen wir mal
wie gut er niederländisch ich glaube
diese übermut gibt es bei vielen aber
auch bei den deutschen die sagen ja wir
können doch alle niederländisch brauchen
das gar nicht zu lernen aber auch auf
der seite der belgier würde ich sagen
dass sie ja deutsch und meine freundin
sagen dass auch die haben mich dann zum
beispiel in hamburg besucht und dann
kommen die machen die große augen und
sagen oh es ist irgendwie doch sehr
unterschiedlich wenn die leute das
irgendwie schneller sprechen also man
muss aufpassen was man sagt so ja stimmt
es ist sehr interessant weil ja ich habe
auch früh angefangen niederländisch zu
lernen mit 16 so wie du deutsch oder
noch früher gab ich und das ding ist du
kommst sehr schnell auf ein level wurde
schon ziemlich viel verstehen und
sprechen kannst und viele leute bleiben
aber dann stehen und gehen nicht weiter
und dann ist es schwierig weil du kannst
dann eben doch nicht über politik
sprechen wenn du nur zwei level hast und
dann verstehst du auch nicht anders okay
jetzt kannst du einen spontan satz auf
nieder nichts sagen und ich sage ihnen
auf deutsch
sagen wir mal dem mittelstand da wo da
in der mitte steht eine steht ein tisch
genau ganz kurz gesagt das war auch ein
test für mich okay in einen noch einen
satz noch kandidatin nützen embryo kari
trägt eine mütze und eine brille
als nächstes haben wir noch einige false
friends und das sind wörter die ähnlich
klingen oder vielleicht die gleiche
entsprechung haben in der anderen
sprache aber etwas anderes bedeuten bist
du bereit ich bin bereit aber ich muss
sagen das ist wirklich ein minenfeld
zwischen ihr zeug sprachen dass es ja
mal sehen es gar nicht so einfach
ja das deutsche wort wie das heißt auf
niederländisch wer also wenn man auf
niederländisch sagt wie hilft dort hier
dann fragt man wer hat das getan und
wenn man dann auf niederländisch wie
fragt also wirklich auf welche art und
sagt man who hilft herdan
wie hat er das getan wir schütteln mit
dem kopf er ist jetzt schon verwirrt und
wir haben nur zwei wörter vorgelesen
dürfen heißt auf deutsch ich darf nicht
rausgehen denn ich bin krank sagt man
als beispiel was heißt dürfen auf
niederländisch also es gibt ein wort das
ich sehr ähnlich anhört dürfen
und wenn ich sage ich dort nichts dann
heißt das ich traue mich nicht und dass
solche worte mögen ich mag kein keinen
kuchen zum beispiel was würde was würde
das auch niederlassen
es gibt was sie ähnliches wenn ich sage
ich mache dort nichts dann heißt das
dass ist mir nicht erlaubt ich darf das
nicht also dürfen also das ist wirklich
so ein kreuz was man da machen kann
oh ja lacht schon und schlägt sich die
hand über den kopf zusammen denn er kann
es nicht fassen ja ein beispiel was wir
schon gehört haben
der tisch auf deutsch ist auf
niederländer der tafel und die tafel auf
deutsch ist auf niederländisch hatte bis
der teller auf deutsch
das ist auch auf niederländisch also wir
unterscheiden nicht
die tafel an der wand ist ein bus und
der teller auf den tisch ist ein bus man
schreibt etwas an die tafel
aber davon ist wirklich ich esse aus 100
steht auf der tafel das ist wirklich nur
dieser tisch davor so schwierig am
anfang
wir kommen jetzt zum großen finale
nämlich zum live test wie gut kann
jemand der deutsch spricht
niederländisch verstehen
und weil ich schon ein bisschen
niederländisch kann werden wir jetzt die
amish vor die kamera holen und er hat
keine ahnung von niederländischen und
soll jetzt mal einen kurzen artikel
übersetzen bzw
nina du hast den vorlesen und janisch
muss dann sagen was er verstanden hat ja
ich gebe euch die das mikrofon
los geht's okay der titel leute
buschbränden in australien ums leben
die buschbrände in australien sollen
auch uns wehtun
das war schon ganz gut tun uns werden
wir nicht ganz richtig das heißt so viel
wie schwitzen lassen wir benutzen da das
tun als quasi als mode verb also es tut
uns weh tut uns treten es ist lasst uns
schwitzen aber die die gemeint ist wir
sollen auch angst haben wer ist
schwitzen kommt davor davon dass wir
auch angst haben ja weil das nicht nur
australien betrifft australien sondern
auch uns ja da war noch ein kleiner
untertitel der ofen wanderwitz der ofen
von der welt genannten beträgen jährige
brust brauchen menschen die in
australien die in australien so alle
männer oder alle menschen zu bekämpfen
etliche buschbrände
cindy in dem trockenen australien
das habe auch schwierig handeln heißt
schon monatelang schon monate auch ist
das schon und betreten ist bedrohen levy
cottbus bringen so heftige bus ist bald
also waldbrände
wenn sandy mensch und tier in australien
in australien
ja ich bin begeistert deine
niederländische skil sind ja ganz gut
oder was würdest du sagen ja bei uns am
10 auf 10 10 von 10 90
ja das waren die unterschiede und
ähnlichkeiten zwischen deutsch und
niederländisch danke dass du dabei weiß
nina sehr gerne extra heute nach berlin
gekommen um mit uns zu drehen das hat
uns sehr gefreut wir freuen uns auf eure
kommentare was denkt ihr sind deutsch
und niederländisch sehr ähnlich habt ihr
vielleicht jetzt auch lust bekommen
niederländisch zu lernen das empfehlen
wir euch auf jeden fall denn wenn ihr
deutsch könnt dann ist das gar nicht so
schwer
und wir haben noch eine bitte für alle
die niederländer sind oder belga falls
ihr lust habt auch solche videos zu
machen wie wir machen in deutschland
dann meldet euch doch gerne bei uns denn
wir suchen tatsächlich partner für
unsere seele gutes netzwerk und würden
uns sehr freuen wenn wir so was wie sie
german auch in den niederlanden oder in
belgien hätten als sie das und wenn ihr
lust habt ein bisschen ansprache an
videoproduktionen dann seid ihr perfekt
in unserem netzwerk aufgehoben schreibt
uns aber wenn ihr das brauchen wollt
schreibt uns am besten direkt eine e
mail links sind hier unten
danke fürs zu sehen
[Musik]